et en vient justement où affluent des
migrants en provenance des brésil et
surinam voisin un collectif de citoyens
a interpellé une nouvelle fois les
pouvoirs publics sur les étrangers il
n'hésite pas à faire l'amalgamé entre
insécurité et immigration jusqu'à
pousser les élus à prendre position il
son patron commerçants artisans
militants il dresse une liste des
mesures qu'ils jugent urgente et
souhaite rallier d'autres citoyens à
leur cause c'est l'aspect semaine la
cité guyanaise dans son ensemble qui
doit dire non à la délinquance à la
préfecture avec le directeur de cabinet
il est question d guyanien et des squats
mais à huis clos mais très vite
l'entretien tourne court metteur en
scène nous proposant le rapport de force
on va jouer ce rapport de force c'est
comme ça que le collectif est ni bhl
quelques mois pour aider légalement et
par ses propres moyens une propriété à
expulser les occupants d'hui aniane sa
maison à cayenne les étrangers sont
publiquement stigmatisme de plus en plus
je dirais que les gens n'ont plus peur à
dire je commence à en avoir assez
parce que celui là et comment ça
m'embêtait fois qu'il a chez lui a prêté
du nord à l'étranger ou a baptisé donc
quelqu'un qui est qui dérange nous
pensons qu'il faut mettre une pause sur
l'immigration en guyane
c'est à dire se donner les moyens de
arrêter cette immigration après
plusieurs courriers au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est officiel le maire
socialiste de cayenne sera reçu le 27
septembre par nicolas sarkozy il emmène
avec lui deux membres du collectif